[Music]
hello everyone how you doing Pete also
known as snail dough here to give you a
another first look video of a game given
to us by rising star games called decay
of logos now this game they asked us to
give you guys our impressions on it now
I played it for about an hour an hour
and 15 minutes and not gonna lie to you
it was a little bit difficult for me but
I wanted to give you guys an honest
answer of what was going on with it so
one thing I want to tell you about was
the graphics of it the graphics of it
are beautiful they are clean they're
crisp they're so intriguing I found
myself really really entranced by how
the graphics looked and how I was
running on the horse and and when I was
using abilities and when I was source
wiping the graphics were great and then
after you go through a little bit of a
tutorial you end up going into this
cinematic like little cutscene and I was
just more entranced I was just like wow
these graphics are great this is amazing
and I was like all right this is cool
yeah horse you're gonna get that you're
gonna end up getting you know you're
gonna get you're gonna get that you're
gonna be able to run around you're gonna
be able to art let's sword fight so the
first thing that happens when you get
into the the next area and you know you
get you get your horse and your horse
pretty much it's walking around you try
to mount it you can't have to apparently
feed your horse to allow it to run I was
like what we just we just went through
this whole entire process I know I can't
even use the horse it doesn't make any
sense and then after that you you end up
starting to go through a fight after
fight through people and there's little
pillars and every single time you touch
a pillar it ends up giving you some more
information of what's going on within
that world and environment and those
were little little tidbits of
information on those pillars and I
thought that was really cool now
that to be totally honest with you guys
from from the start I felt really really
the controls were very clunky now I've
played a handful of different types of
these Dark Soul esque games you know
ashes of remnant III played a little bit
of Dark Souls not much back in the day
when it was on it was on console and the
controls felt pretty solid but with
these controls I felt very clunky like
every single time I tried to target IO
targeted nano an untargeted I have to
target again and I would try to roll and
I wouldn't roll with right and every
time I tried to block I would miss a
block you know it did it didn't seem
right and when I did block filing he
didn't really even show it as a block or
anything and then when I hit the attack
button it was so slow I was like I took
so many hits and I was so aggravated
when doing it that I was I was just kind
of taken back and I said well I'm like
what why is this and then III go into a
room after I go down some stairs and I I
find this barrel and I'm bashing Barros
with the sword to find essentially
healing potions so that I can so I can
stay alive and I found this barrel that
I talked to a monster I'm like really
like you're gonna have mimics in this
like this early in the game I was like
we're fighting treants outside they're
just human trees and now we're finding
these mimics and all they were doing is
just rolling you over it's like you had
no ability to roll out of the way
because the controls are so so wonky
that I just became frustrated and after
that that little bit of time frame I was
like if they got to do an update they
got to fix it they got to do something
to this and I'm hoping after a little
bit of time after they get that through
I'll try it again and hopefully I'll be
able to go through it I mean I'm going
from a game like ashen which has got the
same type of combat and
that was so fluid and it worked out so
well with that no didn't work the way I
wanted it to him I was not happy about
it
now the replay value on it I just wanted
to make sure I was clear with it you
know
beautifully the game is stunning and it
is a game that I would love love to get
more time on and as long as they can fix
that combat it would be perfect so it's
definitely something that I'm hoping to
look forward to so I like to thanks once
again for rising star games for giving
us this code for the decay of logos I
will definitely try to give it a try
again after the updates and thank you
all again I am Pete also known as smell
though here doing this this first look
impression for for this game and
remember iron Lords podcast is on on
Sundays 11 o'clock for the the football
season 1 o'clock during non football
season and we also have a stream team
podcast also Monday nights and that is
at usually 9 o'clock on on our analyst
podcast channel also so thank you very
much for for checking out this
impression and have a fantastic day bye
buddy
[Music]